hello and welcome to this video playing
public Rosen's
Sun scheme alright so what is he playing
the vienna game now you take i was
mostly thinking now I think d4 is the
best move oh is it before him
I think it's deformed it's important to
know that this is bad I can show you
afterwards d4 Knight f3 this is some
this is I think quite good for black in
general this is this vienna game with f4
is a pretty harmless opening like is
fine in in many ways I think just
castles
I mean this is a position where I would
argue that black would have compensation
for a pond but I'm not a pond down funny
enough okay so I wonder maybe the check
em make the King muth
okay do we have anything better than
Bishop to f5 this looks very good yeah
in the intending look the aid and just
attack the King on d1 Luke the aid and
then maybe c5 I mean it's just that this
opening is just bad it's just a bad
opening it is very rich white might be
able to be equal if he is extremely
precise but this is difficult
yeah I would like to play route d5 and
and win but it's not possible I mean it
was Czech I have this move though this
is an attractive move that all that
should basically force resignation Queen
takes Queen c3 for the kill
he's got no way to keep c3 covered yeah
I just if you if you play stuff like
this year the Vienna with their form and
you meet somebody who knows know
something you're just going to be worse
it is not it's just not good I mean it's
good as a surprise weapon maybe
sometimes but yeah these three is is a
trap move the thing is that Queen h4 g3
Knight takes Knight f3 Queen age 595
yeah this is good for what
here's good for what that is a trap I
mean I don't know the details but this
is good for wide so you're only you just
have to remember here this black take
play the form and you're fine that's it
basically yeah nothing nothing else it
is maybe more interesting from White's
perspective I mean taking on d4 I think
it's just immediately better for black
it's maybe more interesting to play form
yet try to give the pawn you can you can
play something like this and now what
did I what did I recommend him I don't
quite remember
[Music]
I don't quite remember what I
recommended I mean black like it's going
to be fine but maybe even I remember
some stuff with Quinn defy that's also
what stockfish is calculating him
Quinn d5 and then quickly castling
queenside I don't quite remember after C
takes it's important to remember the
check this is a lot better than 94 94 C
3 this is actually quite okay for white
but if you check it's a lot better
Bishop d2 take take take and now again C
3 we have this weird this weird position
here it issues bad Bishop g2 f6 and yeah
white has no good reply really what what
do you want to go here after the capture
whoopee eight it's just a disaster right
yes I mean King f2 is better right the
king of two cream shakes and aged for
maybe the engine wants to play this you
know yeah this is probably avoiding to
get mated on directly but I mean White
has for porn Islands and I've got two
yeah but here it gets too ugly very ugly
quickly and actually I had this
immediately that's funky because this is
losing the house and everything else is
losing both rooks yeah okay that would
be nice Group D 8 D form c5 and now hook
it was a it's the killer with this I'm
winning winning everything it's actually
mate I didn't see that this is of course
yeah this is going to be made alright I
hope you enjoyed enjoyed the video
thanks for watching